foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
these two months have been so hard so
aggressive so
tough i mean i couldn't even sleep
i'm saying that it's not going to happen
again like broadcasting from tvs because
it's all under the control of the this
group of taliban and and this is this
needs to be sponsored so there is no
sponsor there is no responsibility there
is no investment
[Music]
ah
this 20 years has been like a
like a fiction story i can say you like
a
like a
like an a realistic thing like i woke up
today yesterday was taliban after 20
years like they came and took the
control and
all i have
been dreaming for that you know
buried on the ground
so
[Music]
i have a bad feeling i have no hope that
this situation or their perspective will
change
most movements are with stretching your
legs that's why it's difficult for them
to allow girls to do taekwondo
[Music]
most of my friends have cut their hair
off that's a psychological impact from
the outside we look fine but on the
inside it's all sadness
[Music]
no cruelty is permanent